as we discussed earlier even if we have
multiple observations we can still find
the structure of the best linear
estimator in a fairly simple
computational way by solving a system of
linear equations but usually we do not
get nice and simple formulas but here is
a nice example in which we will get a
simple formula the example is something
that we have seen before in various
guises we are trying to estimate a
certain quantity theta and what we
obtain is multiple noisy observations of
theta that is at each observation we see
theta plus a noise term the assumptions
that we make is that theta has a prior
distribution with a certain mean and a
certain variance and the noise terms are
zero mean but they have some variance
and the additional assumption that we
make is that all these random variables
are independent of each other so the
noise terms are independent between
themselves and also the noise terms are
independent of theta this is the usual
assumption but actually in the linear
estimation problem we do not need to
make an independence assumption it's
enough for our purposes to just assume
that they are uncorrelated so we will
assume that the correlation coefficient
between any two of these random
variables is equal to 0 now we can write
down the form of the mean squared
estimation error criterion that we have
and try to find good choices for the
coefficients to be attached to each one
of the observations however we are going
to find the solution to this problem
using a shortcut that's going to bypass
all kinds of computations here's the
trick let us suppose in addition that
these random variables were not just an
correlated but independent and that they
happened to be normal random variables
this is a problem that we did study
before and we did find the maximum
a-posteriori probability estimates of
theta because the posterior was normal
we found that this was also the
conditional expectation estimator of
theta and we did find a formula for it
which took this form this was the form
of the optimal estimate of theta if you
obtain values for the different
observations little X I on the other
hand if you want to translate this into
random variable notation then notice
that this is going to be a random
variable this is our estimator
it's the conditional expectation of
theta given X and it's random because it
depends on the values of the data that
we see which are themselves random
variables on the other hand this X 0 is
actually the prior mean of theta so this
is a constant it's not random and that's
why we keep it with a lowercase notation
now what is interesting about this form
it is a linear function of the
observations and as we have discussed
earlier if it turns out that the
conditional expectation is linear in the
observations then this is also the best
possible linear estimator so for the
special case where our random variables
are independent and normal we have a
formula for the best linear estimator
now what if they are not normal suppose
that they are not normal but that they
have the same means and variances as
here as in the normal example since
these means and variances are the same
and since these random variables are
uncorrelated it follows that also all
kinds of covariances between the random
variables involved here are going to be
the same as for the normal example now
the optimal solution to the linear
Meishan problem as we discussed earlier
only cares about the means variances and
covariances of the random variables
involved the details of the distribution
do not matter so whether we have normal
distributions or non-normal
distributions as long as we're making
enough assumptions that fix all the
means variances and covariances of
interest we should be getting exactly
the same solution therefore this
solution remains valid for the case of
general random variables as well